tenemos aquí a la molécula etileno en la
que también se le llama eterno y podemos
ver que hay un enlace doble entre estos
dos carbonos además de que cada uno de
estos carbonos está enlazado con otras
tres moléculas ok aquí están dos
moléculas y esta es la tercera molécula
lo cual es distinto a lo que vimos en el
vídeo pasado en el vídeo de orbitales
híbridos sp3 vimos que el carbono hacía
cuatro enlaces simples con cuatro
moléculas distintas y bueno aquí el
carbono está haciendo un enlace doble y
está enlazado con únicamente tres
moléculas entonces los carbonos del
etileno deben de tener un tipo distinto
de hibridación y para ver qué tipo de
hibridación tienen estos carbonos del
etileno vamos a observar la notación
orbital que nos muestra a los cuatro
electrones de valencia del carbono por
aquí ya tenemos al estado excitado donde
uno de los electrones del orbital 2s ya
fue promovido al orbital 2p que antes
estaba vacío
entonces pasamos un electrón de este
orbital a este orbital en el vídeo
pasado de hibridación sp3 lo que
hacíamos era aumentar el nivel de
energía del orbital 12 s
y como hoy vamos a hacer cuatro enlaces
simples entonces disminuimos el nivel de
energía de estos tres orbitales 2 p
23 23 habrá esta molécula solo hace tres
enlaces por lo que únicamente
vamos a disminuir el nivel de energía de
dos de los orbitales 2p ya están por
aquí y vamos a dejar uno de los
orbitales 2p tal cual como está
y entonces este orbital se queda tal
cual como está pero estos otros tres
orbitales e híbridos en y forman tres
orbitales sp2 gray sp2 de que se están
utilizando un orbital s
y dos orbitales de tipo p y entonces
tenemos tres orbitales de tipo 72
y podemos decir que todos los carbonos
del etileno son carbonos y british a 2
o sea 2 sp2 ok
este es un carbono y utilizado sp2 y
este también es un carbono y brisa 2 sp2
ahora nuestros orbitales sp2 fueron
formados a liberalizar un orbital de
tipo s y dos orbitales de tipo p
entonces podríamos pensar que tienen una
naturaleza del 33% de tipo s y 67 % de
tipo p recuerda que los orbitales de
tipo s son como una esfera chiquita y
los orbitales de tipo p son como unas
mancuernas
y entonces cuando hacemos las cuentas
cuánticas para predecir la forma de los
orbitales sp2 por ejemplo cuando tenemos
un carbono ibiza 2 sp2 sus orbitales van
a tener un lóbulo más largo y otro
lóbulo más chiquito ahora si queremos
comparar los orbitales híbridos sp2 con
los orbitales híbridos sp3 del vídeo
pasado pues vamos a tener que estos
orbitales son más cortos que los
orbitales sp3 porque tienen más de la
naturaleza de los orbitales de tipo s y
estos orbitales son esféricos y
chiquitos y muy cerca del núcleo
entonces pues estos orbitales van a ser
más cortos y más apegados al núcleo que
los orbitales de tipo sp3 y eso la
longitud de las órbitas sp2 va a influir
en la longitud de los enlaces aunque hay
como estos orbitales sp2 son más chicos
que los orbitales de cp3 los enlaces
entre moléculas cuyos orbitales son
2 sp2 van a ser más chicos que los
enlaces de las moléculas cuyos orbitales
son de tipo s p 3
entonces vamos a tratar de dibujar a
esta molécula etileno en su estructura
de puntos pero dibujamos sus orbitales
aunque ahí tenemos tres orbitales
híbridos sp2 y un orbital de tipo p y lo
vamos a dibujar por acá pero otra vez
como en el vídeo pasado de estos
orbitales nada más vamos a dibujar este
lóbulo nos vamos a olvidar este otro
pedazo así es que empezamos con un
carbono por acá tiene una órbita híbrida
sp2 por acá vamos a ponerle otra órbita
híbrida por acá y por acá allí están las
tres órbitas híbridas sp2 y cada una de
estas órbitas híbridas sp2 tiene un
electrón de valencia vamos a colocarlos
así pero la molécula del teleno tiene
otro carbono por acá con otras tres
órbitas híbridas sp2
aquí está una de esas órbitas híbridas
sp2 por aquí vamos a poner la otra y la
última y cada una de estas órbitas
híbridas sp2 tiene su electrón de
valencia ahora la molécula de etileno
también tiene cuatro hidrógenos y esos
hidrógenos tienen una sola órbita de
tipo s y las órbitas de tipo s son
esféricas entonces vamos a dibujarlos
así
y tienen un electrón de valencia cada
una
entonces ya dibujamos todos los
hidrógenos y todos los orbitales
híbridos sp2 pero no hemos dibujado los
orbitales de tipo p de cada uno de estos
dos carbonos entonces pues vamos a
dibujarlos recuerda que los orbitales de
tipo p
son como mancuernas que tienen un lóbulo
por aquí otro lóbulo del mismo tamaño
del otro lado entonces pues más o menos
lo podemos dibujar así y bueno podemos
empezar a contar cuántos enlaces sigma
hay en esta molécula a ver aquí esta
intersección de aquí de estos dos
orbitales está en medio de los dos
núcleos de estos carbonos entonces este
es un enlace sigma ok y lo mismo ocurre
por acá esta intersección está en medio
de los dos núcleos de estos dos átomos y
entonces este es un enlace sigma al
igual que en este caso
en este caso y en este caso entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 enlace sigma ok
todos estos son enlaces sigma ahora de
estos orbitales que tienen x o electrón
que se había olvidado poner estos si se
intersectan para formar un enlace
claramente no se van a interceptar en
ningún punto que esté en medio de los
dos núcleos estos orbitales de tipo p
podríamos pensar que son mucho más
grandes y entonces que se intersectan
por los lados la única forma en la que
se pueden interceptar es y se
intersectan como que del lado estos 2
orbitales gay y a la intersección del
lado de dos orbitales de tipo p se le
llama un enlace de tipo pi y bueno es
más fácil pensar en esto si pensamos que
estos dos hospitales son mucho más
grandes y gordos pero en el chiste es
que la molécula del etileno tiene un
enlace de tipo pin
fijémonos en el enlace entre estos dos
carbonos por un lado tenemos este enlace
de tipo sigma
pero por el otro también tenemos este
enlace de tipo pi que ahí tenemos dos
enlaces entre estos carbonos y por lo
tanto decimos que tenemos un enlace
doble ahora si recuerdas estos orbitales
híbridos sp2 son más cortos que los
orbitales híbridos sp3 y bueno aquí
tenemos orbitales híbridos sp2 porque
dejamos un orbital de tipo p solito para
poder hacer este enlace pib eso explica
por qué los enlaces dobles son más
cortos que los enlaces simples ok para
formar un enlace doble tienes que dejar
un orbital de tipo p solitos y libre de
cear y entonces las órbitas híbridas sp2
tienen más naturaleza de tipo s y por lo
tanto son más cortas y entonces el
enlace doble es más corto entonces pues
vamos a dibujar otra vez la molécula
etileno
pero vamos a dibujar otros aspectos de
ella tenemos aquí dos carbonos y vamos a
dibujar primero nada más los enlaces
signos ok
los cinco enlaces sigmas entre el
carbono y los hidrógenos aquí están los
cinco enlaces sigma este es el esqueleto
de la molécula de etileno y bueno creo
que este es un muy buen momento para
decir que las órbitas híbridas son las
que determinan la geometría de la
molécula y bueno la molécula etileno
resulta ser una molécula plana entonces
podríamos imaginarnos que todos estos
átomos se encuentran en un mismo plano
que estamos dibujando ahorita gate
digamos una hoja de papel a la hora de
dibujar estos enlaces simples solo hemos
dibujado los orbitales híbridos sp2 y
nos falta dibujar los orbitales p de
estos dos carbonos ok en realidad lo
único que nos falta es dibujar el enlace
pi entre estos dos carbonos
entonces dibujamos aquí un orbital p de
uno de los carbonos y podemos ver cómo
se intersectan estos dos orbitales el
chiste es que esta intersección bueno de
hecho estas dos intersecciones entre los
orbitales p forman un solo enlace pib y
ese enlace porque se están interceptando
de lado y en estos dos puntos pero bueno
otra cosa muy importante es que este
enlace pi hace que estas dos moléculas
no puedan rotar a lo largo de este
enlace
ok si hacemos que rote esta molécula de
carbono esta otra molécula de carbono va
a rotar en la misma dirección gracias a
este enlace de tipo pink monkey
generalmente cuando tenemos únicamente
un enlace simple entre dos carbonos
puede rotar todo lo que quieras uno de
los carbonos sin que se mueva en lo más
mínimo el otro carbono pero si tienes un
enlace doble eso deja de suceder ya no
se puede rotar a lo largo de ese enlace
algo que confunde mucho a los
estudiantes es que como ven aquí dos
áreas de intersección a veces piensan
que entonces tenemos dos enlaces pi sin
embargo eso no es así o sea estas dos
zonas de intersección son el mismo
enlace pi que recuerda que todo esto es
un solo orbital de tipo p que en
realidad sólo representa el espacio
donde es probable que uno de los
electrones de valencia de este carbono
se encuentre pero bueno estos enlaces
dobles son los que hacen que no se pueda
rotar a lo largo de este enlace y bueno
los enlaces simples que utilizan a los
orbitales híbridos son los que
determinan la geometría de la molécula
ok los que determinan los ángulos de los
enlaces y si la molécula es plana o no
tenemos que los núcleos de todos estos
átomos están en un solo plano y vamos a
calcular el ángulo de enlace entre todos
estos enlaces entonces tenemos por aquí
360 grados y estamos pensando en la
teoría de repulsión de pares de
electrones de valencia a la que abrevia
mos como teoría 3 p por lo que estos
enlaces o pares de valencia tratan de
estar lo más separados que puedan de los
otros pares de electrones de valencia y
para que estos tres enlaces estén lo más
separados que puedan de todos los demás
estos tres ángulos tienen que ser
iguales por lo cual tenemos 360 entre 3
120 grados entonces este dibujo nos
ayudó a entender un poco cuál es la
geometría de la molécula etileno
encontrar los ángulos de enlace que es
aproximadamente 120 grados y notar esta
propiedad de que no hay rotación entre
estos dos carbonos gracias al enlace ti
pero bueno vamos a volver a dibujar una
última vez la estructura de puntos del
etileno
y bueno sin nada más tenemos la
estructura de puntos del etileno podemos
ponernos a pensar como a partir de esta
estructura sacamos la cantidad de
enlaces sigma que tiene y entonces lo
primero que hacemos es contar cuántos
enlaces simples tiene entonces saber
aquí tiene 1 2 3 4 y sabemos que en este
enlace doble uno de los dos enlaces es
de tipo sigma y el otro es de tipo pi y
como la estructura de puntos realmente
no importa cuál de los dos es enlace pi
y cuál de los dos es el enlace sigma
vamos a decir que este es el enlace
sigma y entonces tenemos cinco enlaces
sigma
y un enlace de tipo y entonces esa es la
forma de analizar una estructura de
puntos y determinar cuántos enlaces
sigma y cuántos enlaces pi hay